jean paul gourévitch justement est ce
que un sujet sur sur l'immigration
serait serait assez important en france
parce que je vais répéter un petit peu
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est à
dire que le sujet est important mais on
ne voit pas très bien quelle question
pourrait-elle faux ou à tête reposée
d'autre part pour et c'est une question
avec une réponse par oui ou par non
sa fracture encore plus une population
qui est déjà très inquiet il n'y a pas
véritablement un choix possible entre
plus d'immigration et moi d'immigration
entre minet immigra salle et une
immigration zéro donc au je crains que
en s'engageant dans cette voie là on
soit dans une impasse sur le fond de ce
sondage est ce que cela souligne que
l'immigration est de moins en moins
acceptée dans notre société française
on le sait si on examine l'évolution des
sondages sur une dizaine d'années on
voit que pour diverses raisons dont
certaines tiennent à la sécurité
d'autres a parfois une certaine
excellent kobe d'autres voix des
problèmes économiques il y a en france
une crispation de plus en plus grande
sur le problème de l'immigration et une
crispation que les médias ne supprime
pas parce que en mettant cette question
véritablement au premier plan ils ne
font que polariser les oppositions sans
chercher si il peut y avoir des
solutions intelligentes et fédératrice
est-ce que ce référendum serait utile
tout simplement je ne pense pas
pour être très sec sur la question je ne
vois d'ailleurs pas oserait proposer une
question suffisamment intelligente pour
que l on évite une réponse soit
totalement positive soit totalement
négative alors c'est un signe lancé aux
candidats à la prochaine élection
présidentielle à droite mais aussi à
gauche n'est ce pas j'ai pas compris
cette question alors je disais que
c'était un signe ce sujet ce référendum
c'était un insigne lancé pour les
candidats à la présidentielle alors il
se peut que derrière cette manipulation
si on peut dire qui consiste à occulter
les enjeux véritables d'une
présidentielle par une chance de
référendum sur l'immigration
on vise à extrême is est d'une certaine
façon la gauche et la droite et ça peut
servir
un gouvernement qui aussi en train sans
provoquer un centre-droit mais je ne
suis pas sûr qu'il y ait véritablement
en manipulation parce que pour l'instant
je n'ai vu personne n'ont pas proposé un
référendum fanning grâce à ça tout le
monde peut le proposer
mais mettre en place une véritable un
véritable débat sur quel est le type de
questions qu'on peut poser à une
communauté française
très mobilisés sur un problème très
sensible migration alors on parle bien
entendu ici de la france mais on peut
aussi également parlé de de l'europe
dans son ensemble est ce que la france
peut-elle
légiférer seul sur ce sujet où tout cela
relève un peu du droit européen
alors on peut parler de l'europe
m'enfin tout le monde sait que l'europe
n'a pas de politique migratoire
chacun des pays faire peu près comme il
l'entend dans son coin et on a bien vu à
propos des problèmes posés par la
directive dublin que certains pays sont
très contents de renvoyer vers d'autres
des grands noms ils volent pas donc je
crois que pour l'instant en l'absence
d'une véritable politique migratoire et
en l'axant justement d'un consensus non
pas sur des idées mais sur des décisions
je ne vois pas bien comment l'europe
peut jouer un rôle important
sinon de dire comme d'habitude en bas
vous vous allez pouvoir et que vous
allez passer loi c'est à dire une fois
de plus et comme le fou merci beaucoup
jean paul gourévitch d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir je rappelle que vous êtes
consultant international